[Music]
hello YouTube just Louis in a friends
this is guns in here and I like to
welcome you for my open Sicilian recruit
our series on Lowenthal Sicilian from
the black perspective now whether you
are completely new to the Sicilian and
want to learn the Sicilian or maybe you
already playing your favorite Sicilian
or any other opening and you want to add
a new cylindric Ruta in your armory then
of course you come to the right place
the greatest thing I like about
Lowenthal Sicilian is that unlike many
of the Sicilians it's all about plants
and patterns rather than memorization
which make him quite unique
so without the further due let's get
started the opening water are very
obvious
efore c5 and as you can see I have
highlighted by the arrows the open
Sicilian start with the move Knight to
f3 however if you open and continue it
other anti Sicilians or gambit moves
such as default c3 Knight c3 etc then
for a time being my recommendation is
you should certainly look for other
authors videos or books until I make a
series about it after Knight to f3 we
are going to continue with Knight to c6
and once again very important Junction
has open Sicilian continue with d4
however white has other choices namely 3
c3 Knight c3 or Bishop to b5 which leads
to a different territory okay d4 CCAP to
d4 Knight captures before
and now white claim in the center with
ePHI and fortunately it also hits the
night white night here has few details
girls but as we will see that if white
wants to give his slight advantage then
he has to play Knight to be Phi which is
in fact the only logical choice in this
position so idea is very simple white
wants to play Knight to d6 and get the
bishop pair so you might think okay we
need to stop it with d6 but guess what
not we are playing this unique move a6
allowing this Knight to land on juicy d6
square once again if you operand
retrieve the knight back then I have
covered those lines in the sidelines
so obviously let's see what is the point
after Knight to d6 well if you have to
play the MU King to e7 then obviously we
are not going to consider this opening
but blacks idea is he wants to capture
this night and after Queen takes he
wants to play Queen to f6 and we have
reached the starting position of the
Lowenthal cesarean so as you can see I
have highlighted by the arrows white has
six Queen retrieving moves and against
each of them not only we are going to
look out the theory but I am also going
to show you some of my own invention in
this line which gives you a very
enjoyable play by black no mental
Sicilian is not a very common opening so
if you prepared very well then you can
definitely use this as a complete
surprise weapon into Naumann practice
well before I finish this intro the one
thing which I always
and I think you should do as well that
whenever you are going to learn a new
opening the first thing you have to find
out that what are the pros and cons of
that opening and accordingly you can
walk on those aspects so let's see first
of all what are the advantages of
playing low in the Sicilian well as you
can see I have put it here in the notes
that number one unlike popular Sicilians
such as Najdorf or the dragon where
every move is a vital in this opening
it's all about plants and patterns and
there is very little memorization is
required
number two the forcing opening moves
that means if you carefully look at the
mordor by force we are reaching the MU
eight queen up six and that means you
can do a lot of research in this line
and get a very good position against
each of the white reply number three and
this is what make worth to learn the
Sicilian it has a very very solid
structure and especially when you are
playing against a higher seed opponent
it is not easy for a white to win
against this line so I guess this
advantages are more than enough to
encourage you to play the Sicilian
what about downside well here it is
number one which I am not fully agree
but yep in some lines the position get
draw is specially Queen captures Queen
so if you are in a must-win scenario
then it may or may not be right choice
for you
number two of course just like any other
opening it required a superior endgame
knowledge as we will see that some lines
by force leads to the end game where a
rook and minor piece endgame knowledge
is an essential part of this opening so
I don't think so it's a big deal anyways
it's a part of our chess preparation and
we should know about this endgame
aspects that's all guys with this small
intro I hope I have encouraged you to
take this Sicilian in your reputa and as
we will go through the series you will
literally enjoy the richness of this
opening well thank you for watching this
video feel free to like subscribe and
comment and we will start our first part
with the side line moves so stay tuned